hello in this video we'll talk about
alzheimer's disease
which is a progressive neurodegenerative
disease and it was discovered by
alois alzheimer who was a german
neuroscientist
alzheimer's is associated with
dementia-like symptoms
so what is dementia dementia is an
umbrella term
for severe loss of memory and other
critical thinking ability
which can cause interference with our
daily
life dementia should not be confused
with alzheimer's
because dementia-like symptoms exist for
several neurodegenerative disease
including alzheimer's now alzheimer's is
most common
in people who are at their late 60s
let's understand the symptoms and signs
of alzheimer's in a layman's term
alzheimer's starts with my loss of
memory
and other cognitive cognitive
disabilities
so a person might forget where he had
kept his car keys
etc but eventually things get more
worsen
as the disease progress he might forget
the way of
his home and with further progression of
this disease
there could be other problems such as
decline in
non-memory aspects of cognition impaired
reasoning or judgment
difficulty in initiating or continuing a
conversation
and a lot of difficulty in facial
recognition
all of these things can make his or her
life
really difficult so these
this particular disease is progressing
over time
and worsening over time that is why it's
a progressive neurodegenerative
disease now initially
the damages appears to take place in
hippocampus
and into renal cortex which are actually
important for learning and memory so
this is the starting point eventually
the problem spreads all around the brain
and with the progress of age it can
really damage the brain and allow the
brain to shrink
from the autopsy report of alzheimer's
patient
it has been seen with where the cases of
alzheimer's
is severe the brain has shrunken even 50
percent
by looking at the cross section of these
brain and histopathological
imaging showed us there is changes in
sulki
and kairai and also the ventricular
architecture
has changed in these brains so
alzheimer's disease can be caused due to
many reasons
like any other disease there could be
two component to it
first there could be genetic reason
behind it
there could be other environmental
reason behind it
or it could be sporadic so
let's try to understand that how
alzheimer's disease is diagnosed
in order to diagnose alzheimer's disease
doctors might ask about
a family history whether somebody in the
family has this kind of dementia like
symptoms or not he can conduct specific
tests for memory problem solving
or thinking ability later on he can
carry out standard medical tests
including blood and other csf based
tests
to explore the possibilities
eventually in case of severe symptoms
doctors might conduct ct scan mri
or pet scan to rule out several other
possibilities
involving brain injury and any other
things
so there are clinical hallmarks
which are associated with alzheimer's
disease
let's look at these clinical hallmarks
and
pathological aspects of alzheimer's
disease
which was described by alloys
alzheimer's
in 1906 so these clinical hallmarks
involves beta amyloid block and
neurofibrillary tangles
let's try to understand what are they so
this is a healthy brain which has
neuronal network glia and many other
cell type
in this brain in each neuron there would
be amyloid precursor protein
this protein is important for neuronal
physiology and functioning of the neuron
it helps in synaptogenesis and
helps in synaptic plasticity so this
particular protein
is important for neuronal function now
like
any other protein this protein would be
degraded and recycled
there are mechanisms which allows this
protein to be degraded and recycled
and several enzymes take part in this
pla in this particular aspect is
alpha secretase and gamma secretase this
cleavage
leads to recycling of this protein but
sometimes there could be a faulty
cleavage with a different set of enzymes
which leads to a fragment which is more
sticky
which can stick with each other and form
aggregates these aggregates are
deposited
outside the neuron and this forms
the amyloid pluck apart from amyloid
pluck
the second aspect is neurofibrillary
tangles
in order to understand neurofibrillary
tongue tangles we have to understand
how microtubules are important for
neuron
microtubules are like highways
on top of which cargoes can
be transported with the help of several
molecular motors
now these highways or microtubules are
stabilized by several proteins
such as tau or map etc
this allows proper neuronal transport
and physiology
due to some aberrant reason there could
be phosphorylation in these
tau proteins which don't allow tau
protein to interact with the microtubule
instead they clump with each other and
forming something called neurofibrillary
tangles so neurofibrillate tangles are
found inside the neuron whereas plugs
are formed
outside so these are two clinical
hallmarks
which allows us to detect or understand
about
alzheimer's disease but apart from these
clinical
hallmarks recent research has shown
apart from neuron the glial population
in the brain is also affected
in alzheimer's disease so we have
astrocytes
microglia oligodendrocytes as glial
population in our brain
microglia can recognize these
extracellular plaques and can get
activated and thereby secreting several
cytokines and these cytokines have
average effect
they can excite these astrocytes to
become
reactive astrocytes and these reactive
astrocytes can interact with the neuron
in a toxic fashion
overall these interactions between
different cell types
might lead to brain inflammation and
this is the current understanding about
several cell types how they interact in
alzheimer's brain
in a working model these plugs are
detected by microglia microglia
interacts with astrocytes with several
cytokines and astrocyte reacts back with
the neuron
leading to a vicious cycle of
neuroinflammation
in alzheimer's patients brain and that
is why
alzheimer's is very hard to create a
cure because there are so many cell
types interacting with each other
which brings out the disease pathology
now it is important to understand inside
our brain there could be different cell
types and each of these cell types would
have different
cell states for example in this case we
see
the reactive astrocytes which are
induced by the microglia
and play critical role in progression of
these disease
but scientists has a lot of confusion
about how these cell types and their
cell state
help in disease progression
now what we know about alzheimer's
disease come from genome-wide
association studies
cell culture based model or transgenic
mouse model
so all these mouse model or transgenic
models help us to
uh devise therapeutic development and
ultimately these therapeutic agents can
undergo clinical trial which would give
us a medication
but the problem is in the market there
is no successful drug
for alzheimer's why is so all these drug
trials that happened which tried to
clear the pluck has
failed miserably so what
what is the lacunae in this approach
let's try to understand this
quickly now the
current treatment option that is
existing in the market
is several neurotransmitter reuptake
blockers
so in our brain there are synapses and
in the synapses
there are several neurotransmitters such
as acetylcholine glutamate glutamate etc
now these neurotransmitters are reuptake
after release
but these drug targets allows
the blockage of these reuptake mechanism
which helps in the cognitive ability and
increase the excitability in alzheimer's
patient
but this cure is partial it gives
a little bit of cognitive improvement
but does not
cure the cause of the disease and still
there is no
medication for alzheimer's
now the reason behind not having a
treatment
or not having proper treatment against
alzheimer's is hidden in the
time of the disease progression when we
think about
onset of dementia like symptoms it's
already too late
so we really don't know what happens in
the early stage of disease progression
let's say a person having dementia like
symptoms in late 60s
we don't know what happened to his brain
in his 40s
is there a way to look at his brain when
he was in 40s
researchers tried to look for early
biomarkers
which would allow the researchers to
find the disease or
try to diagnose the disease in an early
stage
indeed there are some biomarkers which
are csf based
and testing the csf can give us a result
regarding that
for example phosphorylated tau or beta
amyloid can be also found in
csf of alzheimer's patient which works
like a biomarker to
to diagnose the disease early but
further research is important to get
even earlier biomarkers of alzheimer's
disease
now when we talk about mouse model
though mouse is similar with
human there are certain problems because
the risk genes which are associated with
alzheimer's
are not really similar between mouse and
human
for example trem2 or apoe these two
genes
are 50 identical in terms of their
amino acid sequence identity so there
are a lot of differences between mouse
and human models and a lot of
pre-clinical trials has been done on
these mouse models
in short we need a model
which is more human-like with the
development of stem cell technology
researchers has developed
organoids which are like mini brains
now researchers can take induced
take skin cells from patients and make
induced pleura protein stem cell from
that
or from human embryonic stem line
stem cell line organoids can be
developed
these organoids also show black
formation
so now it is possible to look at a
person from its
early stages of disease progression his
cells can be taken from his body
it can be induced to become a
pluripotent stem cell
later on the brain organoids can be
developed from his cells
and it can be assessed for risk of blood
formation
or risk risk of alzheimer's like
symptoms now it would help
to detect the disease fairly early
so it can give a better treatment so so
this organoid based technology holds a
huge
potential in future clinical research in
short eddy patient
skin cell can be converted to ipsc and
from these ipsc derived organoids
scientists are now trying
to understand the alzheimer's
progression with
multi-omics approach including single
cell transcriptomics proteomics and
electrophysiological studies
this would if this would kind of
bring out several mechanisms which are
involved in this disease progression
in near future so in summary we
learn what is alzheimer's disease
what are the signs and symptoms how this
disease is diagnosed what are the
cellular and molecular complication in
alzheimer's brain
and what are the available treatment
options and what are the latest
research in alzheimer's field so i hope
you enjoyed this video if you like this
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe
you can also support my channel in
patreon my lectures are also present in
an academy which is india's biggest
learning platform
you can use my code ap 10 to get a 10
discount
if you want to support my channel you
can support me in patreon or you can use
bim upi
to pay me a small amount even your small
contribution
means a lot to me please let me know in
the comment how you like my video thank
you